I have one more question and you know
all the ladies are free to chime in but
I sort of wanted to pose this to Jasmine
because um she's uh she's a legend in
her own mind I guess um what is what is
your best what is your best solution for
men today because you've openly
criticized um people that have offered
Solutions you've said a lot of their
Solutions are wrong uh they're what do
you say they're disconnected from the
world so what would your solution be to
the differences at the sex right now
have the Divide you know the opinions
that men have of women the opinions that
women have of men that that keep them
apart what is your solution to all this
because I mean you must have put some
thought into that yeah and I I I'm gonna
steal from Richard Reeves here um one
thing is I think we need to reverse like
the education Gap has not only like
completely gone away but it's reversed
and so we need more men to be able to
like starting men one year later because
they're they their brains develop later
than us I think that could change a lot
of things getting men more into heal um
health education Administration literacy
jobs um especially as with AI Automation
and stuff those like brute kind of like
Factory type jobs are not going to be
around anymore I think men just like
women we've put such a push for women to
uh find more value in themselves other
than being at home and being a homemaker
I think we do need to put a push for men
to realize that their role is a bread
winner and their how much money they
have and how physically strong they are
that they are more than those things and
they are they have value inherently as a
man as a person instead of just those
few factors so those are a couple things
that I I I push really hard for um yeah
have you seen any of those work in real
life like in action I haven't seen what
you guys say work in real life either
but yeah I mean I do know that uh
talking to two men that live it when
there has been these policies pushed are
you listening you're talking to two men
that live
it okay I also have hundreds of men in
my community that also live the ex
Rel it's like being in a hospital and
being like all the people I see are sick
yeah because you have a show where this
kind it's going to attract that kind of
man so I understand that but you're the
single one that's not in a relationship
moff and I are are fine we've got
hundreds of guys in our community that
are doing just fine how we can help men
and how utilizing our skills and tools
so I'm asking you how your skills and
tools have panned out you haven't seen
them pan out well I have if you look if
you let me even pull up the book I can
give you examples of when read the book
I'm asking for when when I mean you
can't even use yourself as an example
when we use these well am I not a man
what am I trying to if you guys are
saying you're man are you giving I'm
asking you for solutions for the Sexes
for men and women bring them together
policy positions what we've seen is that
when those policy positions have been
implemented it has seemed to improve the
lives of men by quite a bit yeah you're
talking about the college education that
sort of draws them into the 20 year
statistics with you know no no no I'm
talking about I'm talking about
sucessful over the 20 years was it no
I'm saying it's help to men to to to get
educated to have access to better paying
jobs to also why so they can be married
for 20 years and be
miserable I can't hear you you're like
breaking up I don't so they could be
married for 20 years and be
miserable why are they miserable if
they're see you're just making [__] up I
don't know how to answer this question
for you how am I making it up if it's
here in a statistic that I pulled up
well first of all link me that study but
I don't think that they're necessarily
all miserable you said what two they're
not is by CTO and Aon does long-term
relationship can you shut up for a
minute so I can finish talking no you're
so annoying you invited me on I was do a
long-term relationship kill romantic
love why that's the title of the study
go you asked me for the title I'm giving
it to you okay link a piece of paper
Jasmine that's why I'm reading you the
title and the statistics shows that men
who are educated are men who have better
options in the in the economy are worse
off in marriage because that's the
advice I was I've never done this before
but I kicked a
guest I had to do it I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out